le complotisme il est fou du point de
vue de l'analyse pour à quelqu'un des
sciences sociales c'est à dire que c'est
il faut distinguer les complots du
théorie du complot il ya des complots
dans l'histoire c'est à dire des
manipulations cacher le complotisme ou
la théorie du complot c'est de dire que
l'explication principale d'un événement
ou des processus historiques c'est la
manipulation cacher alors que pour un
chercheur en sciences sociales
il ya toujours plusieurs facteurs en
interaction pour expliquer un événement
est un processus
donc il est faux du point de vue
intellectuel le complotisme pourquoi il
participe à l'extrême droite isation
parce que dans cette logique disons de
monter des thèmes ultraconservateur ces
thèmes sont montés à travers cette forme
on peut la théorie du grand remplacement
renaud camus on trouve des formes de
complotiste exil zemmour c'est alain
soral et c'est le cadre ultra que
l'extrême droite idéologique et
fortement complotistes elle sa critique
passe par la dénonciation de
manipulation cachés par des personnes
bon et elle correspond à un effacement
d'un pilier intellectuelle qui a été
celui de la gauche depuis la fin du
xviiie siècle c'est l'association entre
nous critique sociale structurelles et
l'émancipation
c'est à dire la technique sociales
structurelles c'est de dire que
évidemment il peut y avoir des
manipulations etc
mais il ya des structures de classe il
ya des structures de domination sexiste
acial etc qui sont hors de la conscience
même qu'ils sont des formes un personnel
le complotisme d'une certaine façon
c'est de penser leur vie le monde social
comme un film d'espionnage
quant à james bond alors que la critique
des sciences sociales elle est proche
d'une série comme les films de matrix 1
c'est à dire une machinerie un personnel
ou encore comme skynet 1 le robot de la
série des terminators ce sont des
machineries un personnel qui insère nos
vies c'est ça que permet de voir la
critique sociale structurel et le
complotisme lui a une vision assez
simpliste de du blockbuster américain
oui
[Musique]